Trascrizione: Debora Serrentino
Revisore: Denise RQ
[Tre nuotatori pronti a tutto...]
[Il mare in pericolo]
[45 km a nuoto in 5 giorni]
[30 km di coste non balneabili]
[4 giorni per portare il messaggio
a migliaia di persone]
[Depuratori]
[Aree protette]
[Controlli affidabili sull'acqua]
[Riprenditi il mare!]
[Segui EcoOnda]
Marco Cuomo (parlando ad alta voce
come un venditore): Il Golfo di Napoli,
30 chilometri di costa
non sono balneabili.
Dopo 17 anni di commissari straordinari
e 600 milioni di Euro spesi,
il fiume Sarno continua ad essere
uno dei fiumi più inquinati d'Europa,
e 25 scarichi su 31 non sono a norma.
Dichiarato lo stato di crisi ambientale.
Paolo Santalucia:
Anche questa cartina lo mostra,
le bandierine rosse
delle zone non balneabili
stanno soverchiando quelle blu
delle zone dove si può nuotare.
Secondo me non c'è più niente da fare.
MC: E no, Paolo. Invece è proprio
nei momenti di crisi così profonda,
forse proprio perché stiamo così inguaiati
che è giunto il momento di agire.
È nei momenti di crisi profonda
che la gente si unisce,
alza la testa e fa cose
che non ti aspetti.
PS: Insomma è andato un po' così.
Pensavamo di essere in uno stato
in cui a nessuno interessasse
più del nostro mare,
che fossimo condannati
ad avere un Golfo privo del suo mare.
Invece quando abbiamo lanciato
l'idea di EcoOnda, 44 chilometri a nuoto,
dalle bellissime
coste della costiera Amalfitana,
fino alle zone non balneabili
del Golfo di Napoli,
in tanti hanno deciso di aiutarci,
di sostenerci e di nuotare con noi
per fare in modo che questa protesta
diventasse una proposta.
MC: Infatti prima di lanciare
l'ennesimo grido
di dolore disperato ed isolato
abbiamo provato a coinvolgere
le famiglie, le associazioni,
ma anche le amministrazioni, provato
a portarle dalla nostra stessa parte
E così un'idea che era nata
da tre amici, si è via via allargata
e la gente ha iniziato a donare
non i soldi, ma il proprio tempo
un pezzetto del loro mestiere,
delle proprie conoscenze, del loro sapere,
ed è cresciuta EcoOnda
soprattutto tra la gente comune,
persino tra gli scettici,
quelli che ti aspettano e ti dicono:
"Teniamo da fare, abbiamo da lavorare,
l'ambientalismo è roba da snob".
In realtà, ci hanno risposto,
che qui nel golfo, senza un mare
più pulito, non si può lavorare.
Oltretutto abbiamo scoperto
decine di piccole associazioni
che lavorano tutte però isolate,
nella tutela del mare,
di un sentiero che conduce
ad un tratto di spiaggia, di un litorale.
Noi abbiamo chiesto loro
di lavorare e di nuotare uniti,
per una settimana nella stessa direzione.
PS: Per esempio l'associazione
ambientalista "Mare Vivo"
è diventata nostro partner principale
e farà educazione ambientale
lungo tutte le tappe di EcoOnda.
Il comune di Vico Equense
ha già deliberato la creazione
del miglio azzurro,
cioè di due chilometri di mare
senza barche a motore.
MC: Infatti, noi partiremo
a nuoto dall' 11 luglio da Positano
e nuoteremo nelle acque cristalline
del parco marino protetto
di "Punta Campanella",
entreremo nel Golfo di Napoli,
arriveremo a toccare le prime zone
non balneabili di Castellammare
e torneremo indietro a Vico Equense.
Esistono dei tratti di questa traversata
che sono aperti a tutti,
in questi tratti noi contiamo
di avere al nostro fianco
decine e decine di nuotatori
ed ogni spiaggia che andremo
a toccare avrà iniziative differenti:
avrà pulizia dei fondali, pulizia
delle spiagge, giochi per bambini,
tutti improntati ad aumentarne
il grado di percezione
delle problematiche legate al mare.
PS: Speriamo che questo sia solo un inizio
e che questa onda si diffonda
e dimostri che le cose si possono
anche cambiare dal basso,
e che una crescita, un'economia
e un turismo ecocompatibili
sono possibili
anche sul nostro territorio.
PS: Grazie.
MC: Finito.
(Applausi)